it's my pleasure to introduce professor
brian keating
brian is a chancellor's distinguished
professor of physics at uc san diego
co-director of the arthur c clarke
center for the imagination
host of the into the impossible podcast
creator of an increasingly famous
youtube channel
and writer of the scientific memoir
losing the nobel prize
in speaking about the book it has three
aspects which are
interwoven in a delightful way the first
aspect is as a memoir
the second aspect is popular science
writing about the history of cosmology
and particular measurement in cosmology
and the third is a polemic against the
shortcomings and even toxicity of the
nobel prize or the way it is currently
governed
in particular its rules against awarding
prizes posthumously
and its inability to recognize the
contributions of large teams
brian is joining me today to discuss his
book his multiple channels of outreach
activity and his interest
in scientific education of the public so
welcome brian
hello darren that's so great to be on
your podcast
it's a real treat to me can't believe
that it was like
three months ago that we did this on on
your
uh your show i know we you owe me a part
two on my podcast
yeah any time um i wanted to start with
a podcast for which
uh by my count you've produced something
like 45 episodes since the start of
the coven 19 pandemic and also your
youtube channel which mirrors the
podcast content
has gone from i don't want to say
relative obscurity but to definitely not
obscurity to over 12 000 subscribers
over the same time period
how did you manage to do that during the
pandemic
well i you know i don't know if you
remember in the 80s you were you were
too young probably you're playing duck
hunt with that little uh
indeed fisher price tool that you had
but uh
but you know there are all these hair
metal bands that uh you know
would go on tour and you know to me that
the thing that they would always do is
kind of like preening and
and showing off and so forth and i
figured like what talent do i don't have
that much hair i don't have that many
other abilities but um you know as a
consequence of the
global covid pandemic i realized having
been a first-time author
uh uh not too long ago that there were
probably a lot of first-time authors and
maybe
multiple time authors that were having
their book tours canceled
and i figured uh you know kind of
replace a book tour with the idea that
you could do a virtual book tour and
maybe reach a lot more people and i gave
some book
talks at bookstores where you know we
could have had it on
you know on a couch like we didn't need
the whole bookstore for my book reading
uh and i loved every one of them there's
something very vibrant
and uh and and you know very positive
about being in person the electricity
tangibility
uh cannot be matched but given that you
know a podcast like yours or mine might
reach
thousands and thousands of people and
not only be
available for that one hour let's say i
have a scintillating joke or a
rack contour you know or whatever it's
lost forever because you know i'm not
recording it in some coffee shop
but on a podcast forever so i had that
idea that i could reach out to
authors and publicists of authors and
because they were canceled i could get
some really big names
on my show that otherwise i wouldn't be
able to get and then it's kind of this
matthew effect
uh where the rich get richer the the the
better you guess you get the more people
want to come on your show so i got a
couple really
big guests up uh early uh sean carroll
um and uh and others michael shermer
and then uh some people uh in the other
world and i also had
uh because one of my duties here is
co-directing the arthur c
clarke center for human imagination with
my friend
uh eric berry who is a physician and a
phd
and uh the two of us have been putting
on with patrick coleman
and and others from the center uh for
human imagination
events for the past several years that i
had access to
quite a great deal of you know kind of a
great rolodex as we used to say of past
guests and people that have been on so
it was a combination of of you know
trying to make the best of an awful
situation
but really benefiting from the fact that
uh that
there was some name recognition at least
in the arthur c clarke realm and
amongst other authors and and and
publicist
uh and so now i'm actually delighted to
say
i get uh uh i get requests now uh
for to be a guest on my podcast you know
people request to be a guest in my
podcast
and uh you know i have no comment
i have a lot of fun you know rejecting
no no i i don't know
but actually darren you know one of the
people that requested to come on my
podcast is a nobel prize winner and
that'll be coming up soon
and so it feels good to get you know
people that have won the nobel prize the
pulitzer prize
uh great authors that i look up to and
learn from now they're requesting to
come on my podcast because you know
maybe i'm not i'm the only one that will
accept them i don't know it's a lot of
fun though
i'm really enjoying it a lot well it's
pretty unusual to have a practicing
scientist host
a science podcast a lot of times it's
you know i i
i love the i love scientific journalism
i love cycom but a lot of times honestly
it's wow-wee stuff like you know
researchers at uc san diego are you know
curing cancer and you know
and and here's what they're doing um but
it's there's not a lot of peri
scientific
uh podcast you know um
for it's in and it's not like uh it's
not just
shop talk i think people outside of the
scientific community are interested in
how
the practice of science actually
actually goes
um and along those lines what do you
know about your audience
are they scientists or interested
individuals or both
it's funny i kind of liken it to the nsf
proposals that you and i write
and you chronicle so astutely how low
chance of success there are i kind of
always think with these nsf proposals if
you took
all the referee reports at least the
ones that i get um
and you made it as if it came from a
single person so in other words you take
all the reviews it can be excellent
very good whatever and all their
comments and you just mash them together
and say this is one person
who said all these things about your
proposal that person would be
incarcerated or
you know in a psychiatric ward of a
hospital
because it's so diverse the the opinions
this is the best proposal ever it must
be funded to
i can't believe this person is actually
a professor at least again this is for
me
you've never seen reviews like that like
very bad i don't know
surely not
you've never seen a very bad right um
but anyway
uh the so my audience is kind of like
that like i do
interviews with people ranging from you
know people that are my heroes
uh uh carl sagan's widow i had uh
andrean on my show
and i got to use my little carl sagan
finger puppet
uh and show it to her and then her
daughter sasha sagan
who's also an author so uh i get these
great
you know kind of one-of-a-kind
interviews and then
500 people will watch it which is not
i'm not you know criticizing that but
it's just like i just spent an hour and
a half of one of the most brilliant
authors in the world
who was connected to one of the most
brilliant astronomers of all
time and there's only 500 people that
want to watch it on the other hand i'll
have something with like
a pioneer of anti-gravitational
research in the microscopic first
moments of the big bang
and uh uh you know wormholes and
multiverses that there's no
physical evidence for uh whatsoever as
yet
uh and that'll get tens of thousands of
views and it's just it's really hit or
miss so
um uh what's what's nice is that i i get
to talk to who i want to talk to
and and that's something that's really
been a blessing
of this podcast you know pandemic
podcasting for me
which is that um you know a lot of times
you and i are on calls
because we have to be on zoom calls and
we don't really want to like i've been
looking forward to this chat for a long
time
sorry i rescheduled it many times but
like i could probably talk to you for
hours
and and it's really fun but you and i
don't work together
at least not yet maybe someday we could
uh but but the point is i
i respect your intellect i like your
questions i i like
talking to you and learning from you and
about you and all the various things
that you're doing there's so many people
just at ucsd that we could just
interview
um but but most of the time i'm on
telecons with vendors or you know
tracking down a screw
like i'm not stroking my non-existent
beard contemplating the biggest things
in humanity
such as how do you access you know uh
the public how do you
uh what's the obligation of a scientist
to communicate et cetera so
i break it down to what i have to do
versus what i want to do and
you know i always joke for an astronomer
i spend
lots more of my time on telecons than on
telescopes which is
exactly the opposite of the way i
thought it would be as a kid
sure and when they sell you the idea of
being a professor at an r1 university
they you know some huge percentage of
the pie is research
you know then teaching then service but
really the research part
of the research section of the pie is
maybe a tiny slice of that and the rest
of it is
administration and tracking down screws
and stuff which
is not teaching and not service so yeah
i guess it's research
so this is i think the venue in which we
can really play with ideas
uh did you have to negotiate with ucsd
to um you know provide all of this
free content free service
no i mean though it's kind of like my
book uh the
the advice i got from a former
chairperson was you know
we won't penalize you for writing a book
like we won't actively destroy your
career for writing a book but we're not
going to give you time off we're not
going to give you
you know a sabbatical or they're not
gonna do and the same for the podcast
it's kind of flown under the radar
screen so if pretty
finds out about this uh he might get
upset uh but
uh but you know i i do it in in kind of
mostly in my in my spare time a lot of
it i do from home
nights and and the weekends and i i just
i
you know i think we were the ucsd's
first podcast down there's a couple
including yours
actual podcast on itunes started in 2016
or so with freeman dyson and then just
an amazing
kickoff to it it was kind of dormant for
a long time i did start the year with
about a hundred subscribers on my
youtube channel and it's grown a hundred
times
uh but uh and i'd like to think i'm
bringing these great
you know kind of intellects to the ucsd
community
and for them to benefit from it and a
lot of it has to do with science you
know today i'll be doing one with sean
carroll again
and uh it brings a lot of attention to
to the research that we're doing here
in my group and in allied groups and
that are affiliated with the arthur c
clarke
center for human imagination so um
no there's no there's no uh i wouldn't
say it's positive or negative in terms
of support or
or being penalized but it uh you know
it's
it's as you know it's a lot of work to
do the research um
but like you i i grew up reading a lot
and i love to read popular science
uh works and i never thought i would
write a popular science book
uh but here here here i am two years
afterwards
and i'm thinking about you know four or
five more books coming down the road
because it's sort of addictive the way
that podcasting can be addictive
in a good way and hopefully it's a
healthy addiction uh you know
my wife thinks you know based on how
much money i spend thanks to
darren's recommendations sure
i might go out of business but uh but
it's been a lot of fun and
you know i think the keeping the
intellectual tradition alive at ucsd
where we're not just siloed thinking
about you know the screw
side of things we're thinking about the
universe and the biggest pictures and
the smallest molecules in the universe
fantastic oh who were your favorite pop
science
authors growing up who did you read you
know one of my favorite quotes from my
my favorite writing book which is the
sense of style by stephen pinker
he said that behind every
uh every great writer is a you know a
great reader um so who are your
uh who are your heroes i think uh
i think the uh the the kind of saying
that
goes along with that to me is great
teachers were once great students so i
think
there's a there's actually and you give
a lot of great tips for this in your
podcast
um you should there's a there's a
practice of being a student and as you
know at least for me
i don't know how it is in in your
department uh but
uh they don't teach us how to teach so
we kind of have to cobble together
mentors that might be long dead
as they were in my case for readers that
i read growing up uh
you know one of the most important was
carl sagan to me growing up
sir roger penrose the first popular
science book i ever read was the
emperor's new mind
as a high school student uh and that was
very influential on me
uh his right and now he won the nobel
prize two weeks ago and i've had him on
my podcast four times
uh he's as gracious as he could possibly
imagine
uh and the other you know kind of being
influenced on me was
isaac asimov who wrote 400 books
uh he was a professor also i think at
boston university right yep
yep it's all biochemistry yeah and he's
uh he's kind of the the person i model
myself i actually named my oldest son
isaac after him well and isaac newton
uh as well can't can't hurt and yitzhak
pearlman for uh violinist
love that i have but instead you know
those
uh he wrote a lot of science fiction but
i actually gravitated
away from that and more towards the
science uh nonfictions popular science
wrote many books about chemistry as you
know and and uh the elements and just
page turners as a 10 or 12 year old and
the other one that's
um uh it's kind of fun for me because i
get to read
galileo and an original galileo
uh you know kind of translation by
stillman drake in the 60s
and i'm doing a podcast series where i
just go through the dialogue
and what does it mean to me and what
kind of discoveries was he thinking
about and
and how did galileo fall victim to
confirmation bias and all these things
that we
deal with nowadays in science and
there's a book that was endorsed by none
other than
not only stephen j gould as one of the
best science books of all time but
albert einstein
so it's been really fun to go back and
do deep dives into that
and the last book that had a great
influence on me i'm also doing a solo
episode about someday when i get the
time
is a book called flatland by edwin
abbott abby
uh uh abbott and he was a
school teacher in the late 1800s and
wrote this
uh fantasy about a square literally the
name of the character is
a square and it's a character lives in
two dimensions and gets a glimpse of the
third dimension
when doing so is heresy and and
basically the consequences of his
actions
it's just an amazing book teaches you to
visualize the fourth dimension
and i think every kid should be exposed
to it it's only
a hundred it's less than 100 pages long
that reminds me of a futurama episode
where
fry has to you know jump over a chair to
where he would normally would have moved
around it or something like that
um tell me about the the process of
getting an academic
um book accepted did you have an agent
what was the proposal process
like yeah so it's um yeah so technically
an academic book i would think about is
more like a textbook or something like
that this is
they call these popular trade books i
don't know why they call them trade
books it's not like you're going to
learn to become a
practicing astrophysicist from old
keating's
manual uh but uh but this is they're
called trade books and
um yeah the first step was really one of
my best friends
his book is somewhere behind me uh
stefan alexander who's the current
president of the national society of
black physicists
he and i went to brown university for
graduate school together and been
lifelong friends and he wrote a book
called the jazz of physics
which also deeply influenced my writing
and he encouraged me to write my book
about this affair where my team and i
the team that i had started but later
gotten kind of
booted out of called bicep2 they uh
they we announced that we had discovered
the earliest evidence for the primordial
evolution of the universe a period of
time called inflation
and this was met with as much fanfare as
you could possibly imagine
press conferences whispers of nobel
prizes for everyone involved
except possibly me which is where the
spoiler alert uh that's where i get the
title from i did not win the nobel prize
um but uh uh but instead
the you know the notion that i could
write a book that i had a story to tell
that's the most important thing because
it's sort of a memoir as you
as you captured in the earlier
description it's sort of a memoir of
what it feels like to be a scientist a
young scientist maturing scientist
dealing with all the things that we deal
with outside the lab i mean you and i
have as much
you know external drama shall we i think
you have do you have children there and
i forgot
yeah so we have children we have all
parents that we're taking care of
um sometimes we're quite ill especially
now with kovid and kids dealing with
it's uh there's tremendous amounts of
stress you know people always would joke
with me one of my friends uh
rabbi a friend of mine and say uh you've
got the easiest job in the world i
always joke
it's the hardest three hour a week job
in the world but it's actually
it it never stops i mean as you know you
could be thinking about something like i
was thinking about something i needed to
do
for you know some report that's laid and
some implants it never stops yes we're
in the classroom three hours a week
trust me darren and i are working you
know 90 hours a week or more
uh hopefully pradeep and the governor
and newsome heard that
but but getting back to the subject i
wanted to write a book um
only if i had a story to tell and i
think you know people don't want to read
a memoir about someone they've never
heard of
and so for me the the hook was kind of
what does it feel like to aspire to
something it could be anything it could
be
getting a professorship it could be
being class president making law review
uh it could be whatever you want but
most of us don't get the thing that we
want or even if we do get it
like we win the world series it's
there's no world series team that wins
every single year
so eventually you're going to have to
deal with loss and how do you deal with
that in academia
that was what i wanted to to grapple
with so i got an agent through my friend
stefan
that was hard and then it was pitched to
a bunch of publishers
and all but one rejected it but all it
takes is one and that was my wonderful
publisher at norton and things happened
for a reason maybe
uh and it couldn't have been a better
experience for me uh to work with them
produce a book that's
you know beautifully bound and you know
i my kids
you know have their own copies of it and
they love to to play with it and one of
my sons is thinking about writing a
sequel called losing the nobel prize
part two
so that's that's going to be a page
turner but like little things darren
that you'd never think about like i was
like how do you get color pictures
printed
like will they print color pictures and
i was like scared to ask are they going
to make me pay for it you know whatever
here's
one of my mentors together and they said
yeah sure print
color pictures just make it an even
number of pages
and then another thing i want to do
because not everyone cares about the
nobel prize maybe the way you and i do
but if you zoom in closely
you can see there's three gray banded
chapters here here that's where the
problems are right
those are the only chapters about the
nobel prize so i kind of was influenced
by choose your own adventure books as a
kid
and i figured some people don't really
care about the nobel prize actually lord
martin reese who
endorsed my book he's the astronomer
royal which means he reads the queen her
horoscope every week um
he uh he said i i wish you hadn't
written about the nobel prize because
the other aspects of the book
are so much uh more important like the
science behind it but
anyway uh there's a lot that goes into
it getting an agent is extremely
important it turns
out for popular books for writing an
academic textbook you don't necessarily
need one
and nowadays with self-publishing
anybody can write a book
but i say nobody should write a book if
they're the only ones that are going to
read it
and nobody should write a book that's
not you should never read something
that's not edited
so you need to have an editor if you do
have a story within you
i encourage everyone to do it don't even
my next book might not even
might be self-published i'm actually
leaning towards that derivative from my
podcast
actually did
did you have any control over uh
whether there was an audio book version
or how
how did they make that decision to
publish it as an audio book as well
yeah most most um you know uh book
publishers will want to do an audio book
it actually turns out the revenue
share that they get off of audiobooks is
far higher
for the electronic uh ebook edition the
kindle edition or the audiobook
they get 90 plus percent of the revenue
which translates eventually to the
author
if he or she has a low advance and they
earn out what's called your event so
they paid me
in advance you know uh worked out to be
about a nickel an hour
uh given how much time i spent on it but
anyway um i always joke i got bigger
advanced than nietzsche got you know for
all of his books so uh it may not have
been huge in that
in absolute terms but then you have to
pay for rights to the photographs you
have to pay for
uh transcripts if you use transcripts
you have to pay for
um you know some uh some i had all 50 or
so custom illustrations made
by a wonderful graphic artist who used
to work at the san diego union should be
how to pay for that so
ended up being net loss in terms of you
know financial
remuneration but uh but now it exists
and and so the audiobook happened came
out about six months after the printed
edition
they i had the option of recording it
myself i i didn't have the time to do it
it's
three or four days solid of sitting in a
studio in van nuys california in the
middle of the summer i just
couldn't justify that to my wife and and
our kids
so they did that and uh and then the
kindle book
is sort of automatic nowadays but if you
self-publish you can do all that
yourself
you can choose to do it uh your
audiobook uh you could read it yourself
you can upload the kindle and nobody
really care i mean
do you know who published my you know
isaac asimov's books
probably not like what matters most is
that they exist
and you have them and i always say last
thing i'll say before i wrap that part
up is you know
let's say you found a book written by
your great great grandmother
um nobody knew about it and some
collector found it in the middle of i
don't know i'm guessing italy or
i don't know where you're from darren
but yeah i know you're from upstate new
york so they they found it in upstate
new york
you know buried uh in the in the annals
of
some library in rochester uh if you
found that book and it's
a hundred years old whatever how much
would you pay for that book you know
it's your
grand great great grandmother's memoir
of what life was like and she first came
to america i don't know
making it up you'd pay almost anything
for it so conversely your great
grandkids will also want that so
everybody should write a book if they
have a story to tell
that's fantastic and i think one of the
reasons why i was so excited
to have this conversation was because i
am actually interested in writing a book
you offered to uh to walk me through the
process and i figured we might as well
record that conversation because there
would be other people interested in it
and i'm happy i you know i'm really
happy to hear that and i'm also
extending to you and
uh and uh you know if you're interested
any help that you would need through
that process in exchange for ninety
percent of your event no no in exchange
uh uh you know for for continuing
friendship and i'd love to proofread it
i've
i've
actually proofread some number one new
york times best-selling books
uh uh that that have uh that have come
out so i'd love to be of service to you
oh thank you so much for that generous
offer that's great and i will definitely
take you up on it
the other fun thing darren that that i
had the opportunity to get is
you know i have all these blurbs on the
back of my book from roger penrose to
to uh martin reese to ray armentrout our
pulitzer prize-winning colleague here at
uc san diego peter diamandis
millions of you know lots of my friend
stefan alexander
but now one of the treats of my life is
that i've written blurbs for other
people and
it turns out you know for some reason
i've become friends with a lot of
female authors so i've written blurbs
for uh
eight you know best-selling new york
times bestselling books
including four of them were by women and
uh it's just it's just
incredibly gratifying and you turn the
page you turn to the back cover brian
keating author of losing the nobel prize
it's it's it's an incredible feeling
what can i say
yeah so now that you've worked in so
many media
uh books podcast youtube um
live live events uh what is the best way
to get a message
out or are they all interrelated i think
it's
it's kind of like uh you know having a
farm and you don't know what the
previous owner planted and so you kind
of have to
fertilize it and water it and see what
comes up so
i have a pretty active twitter account
um i'm not super interested in
in an instagram i have an account there
but uh but really the most important
thing to know is that
your book is not going to compete with
another nano engineering professor's
book or even another scientist book or
even with my book
your book is going to compete with like
100 million hours of cat videos
on youtube your book is going to compete
with like people driving their kids you
know there's because it's a zero-sum
game it's a finite pie
people's attention is the most uh
precious commodity not not even time
it's a tension like
you have time to watch a cat video
that's not like a great but that's your
attention is going there
so that's the thing to keep in mind i
remember walking down fifth avenue where
all these publishers are i was going to
meet my publisher
going to meet at norton and i realized
like
i've how can i convince the next you
know 10 minutes worth of people like 20
000 people
at rush hour how can i convince every
single one of them to buy my
book and i realize you can't but um but
what you have to do is
try you have to put it out there in as
many different formats as possible
um you know from a blog to your youtube
channel you have a leg up i had no
youtube channel i had a small twitter
account
and publishers want that they want to
know what are your channels
what is your built-in audience and then
i always say like
my i have 12 000 youtube subscribers
most of my videos will get like a
thousand views
and and i'm actually getting more
downloads on my itunes
channel i'm getting you know 5 000
downloads you know for some of my
episodes
um you know so and i've got 100 episodes
so i'm a half a million downloads for
like
you know a podcast by a physicist it's
pretty it's pretty
respectable um but the thing is you know
what's given away for free is valued at
nothing so
be careful on how much you're giving
away but you want to drum up that for
the audience and then
the last thing i'll say is the most
valuable commodity that they say you
have is an email
list not because like youtube yeah you
might get one percent of your
viewers so you know six 100 viewers
might view
every one of my videos but that might be
it but if you have
a thousand people and they all buy your
book they might buy your audiobook
kindle whatever you know that's that's a
very good start most books sell 139
copies
at most you know that's the ad that's a
median book sales wow there's
nine million books on amazon currently
uh you know so
you have to rise above that level and
it's just you know part of it your
publicist will do
but they're kind of stuck in the old
model of like oh we'll put darren at
barnes
noble and the book will be facing out
nobody cares about that so much anymore
so that's
why self-publishing is not a bad way to
go you really don't lose that much and
i'm speaking as someone who
very much enjoyed and plans on writing
another self
another traditionally published book but
for now i think there's a lot of value
uh you know your pop your podcast could
be turned
into a book that will not come out for a
year
and a half potentially or you could
self-publish it hire an editor
a book cover designer an interior
designer people judge books by their
covers all the time that's my joke on my
podcast
and then interior design editor you
could have that book out in in six
months based on that content you already
have written
you know your intellectual property so
i'm not just saying it for you but for
anybody out there think carefully about
you know how much time you want to
spend on the traditional publishing
process it has its good sides and it has
a significant number of
challenges with respect to
self-publishing how do you curate the
opportunities
when on your book tour for example um
you know you might be in a position
where you're going to give away too much
and maybe someone will
listen to the interview and not buy the
book because they already got the
the cliff notes version how do you think
about that
yeah so it depends on the venue you know
i got to speak at google
uh you know i knew i wanted it to be you
know as
attractive as possible as as kind of
in-depth as possible
versus a book reading literally you're
sitting there in front of people at
warwick's bookstore who's been a lovely
supporter of my work
uh here and there are 50 people there
and you're reading through it and that's
that's also great
um the the ancillary kind of um you know
one of my friends james altucher who's
been on my podcast
he's a king of podcasting and book
writing you know he calls it the hub and
spoke approach so like you have a hub
which is your book or you maybe
and then from that are books and the
podcast and and the blog and the
newsletter
and you should do all of that not not to
monitor look you're never going to make
millions of dollars from a book nobody
makes
millions of dollars from the book it's
from other thing and you have a day job
that you love to do
um but if you've already converted it
into your intellectual property
then you want to you know um basically
people can only remember three things
it's it's been studied
you know when you and i give a lecture
they might take away three things an
hour or two hours later and then just
the exponential decay kicks in so i
would say
you know pick three main highlights you
know for me it was it was like the
the story of astronomy and religious
overtones
of of the origin of the universe the
issues with the nobel prize
and kind of redemption and like
overcoming
your your demons in my case and and and
attractions and and and addictions to
things like prizes awards and accolades
and how that could be used to serve
people everyone wants to solve a problem
everyone wants a hack and you've got
like this gold mine of hacks for like
academics and
and uh and you know it's just you have
you can deliver a lot of value to people
and so i'm not worried about you giving
away too much because you have this
very large well of content i'm just that
sounds cheesy but
you know what i mean you've done a lot
of work at all
scales undergraduate graduate even
post-doc
assistant professor and etc and and
proposals and and
so you've got five different you know
main themes just from that
that's unique so you couldn't give it
all away and if you did it wouldn't
like an undergraduate doesn't really
care about like how you manage time as
an assistant professor
right so uh you i don't worry about you
giving away too much actually you want
to give away
you know almost everything so that you
get people interested because again
those damn cat videos can i ask you
about the reaction to your book in
particular
you wrote about a lot of living
individuals
and these are people who are competitors
and there was the potential maybe to
damage some of these relationships
how did that play out yeah it was it was
pretty
uh fraught in some ways with me i mean
as long as you're sort of telling a
truth you can write almost anything i i
didn't want to do that
i wanted to write and uh and be
accurate i didn't want to damage
anyone's reputation as you know
the the kind of power of suicide uh
hangs over my book
and you know i i definitely didn't want
to cause anguish to anyone
of of the characters who you know had
in my mind caused caused some damage to
me but
i didn't i feel like i wanted to be as
positive as possible like i understood
it
i moved past it it made me a stronger
person and now i can
extend that message so you know for some
of it i was
uh i was concerned but more
to treat people as i would want to be
treated if it was true
and then the the main kind of characters
in the book that you're talking about
have all read it
and and have told me you know what what
they thought about it to my face
and and that's fine i haven't had like
you lie you know it's all true it's all
there i've got emails to prove it
uh but but but the point is um you have
to be
you can't you can't say everything and
in that case people would
really suspect oh just sour grapes like
you're just mad
that you didn't win a nobel prize uh
that was the reaction i was most kind of
interested in that the nobel committee
took an interest in what i said and
actually the secretary
general his name is joran hansen i
uh one thing you'll learn once you write
the book your book is that you might get
asked to write
um serials or they're called um yeah
they're basically
extracts from your book that get
published online or commentaries op-eds
things like that
and one of them i published in a
magazine called the conversation
and that was about how the nobel prize
in literature was cancelled two years
ago because of
allegations of sexual harassment within
the nobel committee that rewards that
particular prize
and i made the case that maybe all the
nobel prize should be put on hold for a
year while they take stock of the
damage that has been done in the past
and how they can rectify things in the
future
and he wrote back and i said you know
here's like just one example rosalind
franklin you know should have won the
nobel prize for dna
so he writes back what do you want us to
do uh give the money to her heirs and
her
children whatever and i was like you're
missing the point uh it's not about the
money in the case of the nobel prize
about the prestige and the
and the influence that these people have
and that when you award it to someone
who
deserves it but not all the people who
deserve it uh that's very
detrimental to the history of science
and the and the portrayal of science to
the human
uh to the to to all of humanity and so
but it was interesting because the first
time the nobel committee responded in
public as far as i'm aware
to a criticism of the nobel prize's um
you know shortcomings that i outline in
the book
okay and that was a very successful
outcome
in that case i mean the the goal is to
uh
to change the practice and the people
who are in a position to do it
uh took took notice yeah
i don't know if they've you know one of
my friends wrote me
uh from uh from europe and said look you
were advocating you know all these women
that go to overlook
so you know three women won the two
science prizes this year
uh and then last year you know two years
ago uh donna
uh strickland won the nobel prize in
physics so there's been you know four
women who have and francis arnold won it
uh as well you know so there's like five
women who have won it since your book
your book's making an impact i'm like
i don't know if i could take much of the
credit for that but
uh but but surely it's it's it's an
amazing change to see
and maybe my book played a tiny role in
it who knows
so i i know that uh that you have a bit
of a tight time
timeline here um do i have about five
minutes left is that okay
okay um i wanted to ask for for some
recommendations
are there any podcasts that you listen
to every episode of or 90
or when it shows up in your subscription
feed you're like okay yeah i gotta
listen to that one on
on my commute yeah it's funny because i
did a bunch of
podcasts with podcasters uh just kind of
going meta
and learning about podcasting and those
have been some of my most favorite
episodes so james altitude is someone i
listen to a lot
uh he's become a friend and this is the
interesting thing it's like i've become
friends with some of these people i've
never met
you know i'll never meet them maybe i
mean some of these people like we have a
common follower
uh marwell duane i think her name is and
she follows both of us
and i'm gonna do her podcast and she's
gonna do my podcast and it's
like you know in what universe i believe
she's a practicing muslim and i'm a
practicing jew and i'm like i live here
in california
and i don't i'm not actually sure where
she lives but uh maybe in europe um
turkey and what are the odds that we
could ever meet
and ever see each other and i'm i'm so
looking forward to that yeah that's so
funny she's doing my show on on monday
i don't know when it's going to be
released and i'm looking forward to
doing her show
as well so i think uh james altucher is
certainly one um there's another man by
the name of
jordan harbinger who had me on his show
and i listened to eric weinstein has
become a really good friend i listened
to his show called the portal
and uh the other ones in terms of
science john carroll's mindscape is a
must
listen to for me and he just does a
phenomenal job
uh curating guests and and very deep i
don't listen to you know and i i listen
to some political podcasts on the right
and the left
uh but and i've had on some
controversial people ranging from noam
chomsky on the far left
that shapiro on the far right and i
always say like i achieve neutrality
because i'll have on
these widely despaired people but the
best thing about science is that
intrinsically what i do in astronomy
should be apolitical like
yeah and you and you got them to talk
about stuff
that they don't usually talk about um
yeah and i you know i get i get a great
deal of satisfaction for that
because you know i don't i think we're
too political and i think science can be
a safe space in a sense to like think
about the wonders of our world from the
very smallest to things that you do
to the very largest and then that's just
such a treat for me so
yeah there's there's those those are
some of the the must listens
um and then um i like uh
you know to really just broaden you know
i listen to
standard like npr and stuff like that
but um yeah those are the ones i i
listen to look forward to almost every
week when they show up
do you have a dream guest i know my uh
uh conversations with tyler tyler cowan
his
dream guest is william shatner he really
wants to talk to captain kirk i wonder
do you have a cat maybe i can put him in
touch because i i did so
i got asked to be uh so william shatner
has a new show called the unexplained
uh on cable and uh they asked me to
record an episode about the moon
and its importance in science so i came
within a few feet of him or you know
where he had been
over the summer so maybe i couldn't put
tyler in touch with him
fantastic um in terms of uh people that
are living i i would say somebody like
um i mean i'm just fascinated by by
people on all different sides i i think
somebody like you know an oprah or
or barack obama uh just to just to
try to get inside their head because i
don't think we know them really well and
one thing that
like the people like about my show and i
take the greatest compliments from
is the research that i do and i think
there's something about me being a
professor you being a professor
we do research into an oprah like we're
going to find out something different
than somebody who
you know watches her show or whatever
and and that wouldn't that be
fascinating like what is the science
what does oprah think about artificial
intelligence like has anyone ever
asked her that um what does barack obama
see
as the technological opportunities of
alternate realities
ar vr the simulation hypothesis
i i think that they like that and so you
know
we'll see i i but i i'm very interested
in just
and talking some some people that i
haven't had on um
that that you know i'm looking forward
to having on and some of them have
agreed to it
are really uh are are just ordinary
collaborators uh you know friends of
mine that work
in the same experiment uh david spurgle
who's a very famous guy i'm hoping to
have him on the show
i should put in a plug i don't know when
this is going to come out but in on
november 10th we're doing a special
recreation
of what's called the great debate in
astronomy that set the size scale of the
universe
so we're having uh nobel prize winning
astronomer adam reese
wendy friedman of the university of
chicago david spurgle
janna levin of columbia barnard
university um
barnard college and um um missing
one or two sarah seeger of mit and we're
gonna do a
live stargazing looking at hubble's
greatest hits
because it's the 30th anniversary of the
hubble space telescope as well as the
100th anniversary of the great debate
which uh which really set the scale of
the universe so we're going to recreate
that
uh virtually in a way that the two
astronomers curtis and shapley never
could have imagined 100 years ago so
those kind of opportunities are really
fun and i did another one with pbs
space-time studios over the summer that
got half a million views or so
about theories of everything so those
are the things uh
i am uh looking forward to maybe ed
whitton is
is the one person who's never come on
any podcast
uh and he rejected me uh but i'm gonna
keep working i've got
three or four of his colleagues that are
going to twist his arm
well good luck and we will make sure we
go to press before november 10th
um is there anything you wish i'd asked
but i but didn't
um i think i think we covered a great
deal
i would say you know just again on the
book theme that
you only should do it if you cannot see
not doing it
in other words if it's and i feel this
way about like textbooks and that's why
i wouldn't do a textbook because
i feel like i could but it's not a
productive use of
whatever skills i have uh whereas
a memoir or story or perspectives
philosophical perspectives on what
it feels like to be you or to be whoever
your audience may be
they have a unique story to tell and
they cannot stay in
and they are the only person who can
tell it i knew i was the only person
that could tell this particular story in
losing the nobel prize
um so that's when you should write it
you don't want to get halfway through it
and be like oh man i've got
30 000 words and i'm just not into it
anymore
you won't be able to sustain it so only
do it if the story has to come out into
the world and you are the only
person that can give birth to that story
great brian
thank you so much for doing this thank
you for your time i thank you so much
darren i'm looking forward to you coming
back on the into the impossible pod
anytime take care what follows is some
geeking out about podcast technology
so yeah you inspired me to get some
technology so now i'm gonna
uh you know break your podcast budget
which is probably like mine shoestring
uh but i got a um i got this
uh cheap web camera which is just like a
logitech so i can switch
cameras so there i am and some people
like that view
some people don't um so i'll switch it
back
but what's cool is that um instead of
using zoom
more is a reaction to zoom i'm just so
sick of zoom
i actually started using this uh this
studio recorder setup that works on
skype
so zoom is much lower resolution video
but this does full 4k video if your
camera supports it
so my webcam that you just saw does not
but my facetime camera does
so that's much higher it's much bigger
stream so they take a while to upload
but the fun thing is you can get this
little gadget down here so let me switch
back to my
cool overhead view so in uh it's called
stream deck and it's a little
switchboard
and you could figure it with all sorts
of scenes so i can have just me
just you the two of us split screen
overhead
you and me split screen face to face
split screen so this whole thing does
that uh so that's a lot of fun and then
also you can use it to take chat live in
a live chat scenario so you can take
chat um and it puts the chat comments
up on the screen so people can see their
names and who's asking so you don't have
to read their names and so forth